auf englisch gibt es diesen begriff
guilty pleasure und tatsächlich hat easy
english letztens eine episode zu diesem
thema gemacht ich weiß gar nicht wie man
guilty pleasure am besten auf deutsch
sagt wahrscheinlich so ein kleines
laster oder eine schlechte angewohnheit
jedenfalls werde ich die leute heute mal
fragen was sie für ein guilty pleasure
haben für eine schlechte angewohnheit
und dann schauen wir mal was dabei
rauskommt los geht's
[Musik]
so das war überhaupt nicht geplant aber
ganz zufällig läuft gerade hier als wir
diese schöne anmoderation aufgenommen
haben über die brücke nur heute wollen
wir die leute fragen was sie für ein
laster haben oder für eine schlechte
angewohnheit ja das ist ein gutes thema
tatsächlich also ich würde bei mir
spontan sagen dass ich jemand bin der
gerne im bett liegt und auch manchmal
ein bisschen zu lange im bett liegt weil
ich die decke dann immer so kuschelig
finde das kissen ist so weich und
eigentlich müsste ich wahrscheinlich
auch stehen und meinen tagesplan
beginnen aber das schaffen haben sie
irgendeine angewohnheit bei der sie sich
dann immer so ein bisschen schuldig
fühlen oder so ein kleines laster so ein
tägliches laster oh ja die gibt es bei
videos auf youtube klickst du dich dich
genau
und wieso ist das ein laster und wieso
machst du das gerne so dumme humor
irgendwie aber ist entspannt und warum
hast du das gefühl dass das ein laster
ist warum auch sagen geführt dass das
eine schlechte angewohnheit ist na ja es
kommt darauf an aber ich denke dass man
ja sehr viele pläne häufig hat und auch
sich die selber so setzt weil man sagt
man möchte gerne was erreichen leben
oder man möchte irgendwie gerne
vielleicht auch ja irgendwie mithalten
weil man immer so hört das andere so
produktiv sind und dann finde ich es
manchmal einfach so ja dann fühle ich
mich nicht gut damit denke mir warum bin
ich jetzt eine die so gern im bett liegt
und faul ist manchmal zum beispiel
morgens ganz pünktlich aufstehen um ich
tatsächlich hinzusetzen und jeden zu
meditieren und das schaffen sie nicht
immer orte sind großteils schon aber so
manchmal eben nicht so dieser innere
schweinehund dann wieder da sagt ach
komm du dich noch einmal um kaffee
ja eindeutig kaffee und wieso ist das
eine schlechte angewohnheit ist doch
eigentlich auch gesund aber ich weiß
dass kaufe mir eigentlich gar nicht gut
tut wenn ich viel zu hibbelig und
unruhig und eigentlich wäre es besser
für mich würde keinen kaffee trinken
aber chancen ich weiß einfach so lecker
schmeckt hast du irgendein kleines
laster oder irgendeine angewohnheit die
du oft machst wo du aber eigentlich sagt
oh ich sollte das lieber nicht machen
eine angewohnheit wo ich denke dass ihn
lieber nicht machen sollte
es gibt so viel geld aus schlecht
wofür gibt zu viel geld dass das ist die
frage
das heißt das geld sind dir so durch die
finger und du weißt gar nicht wo es
bleibt ganz genau
darf ich dir vielleicht eine app
empfehlen um seine ausgaben zu decken
genau darauf habe ich gewartet ja
wahrscheinlich irgendwie shoppen gehen
zu viel shoppen gehen obwohl man sie
nötig hätten das passiert glaube ich
ziemlich oft
ok also man redet ja nicht über geld
aber wie viel geld gibt es dann im monat
für klamotten raus soll im schnitt
tatsächlich weiß ich das nicht auch gut
so ich hab mir ab und zu vielleicht dass
das könnte gelten ja ja das könnte noch
runter schrauben dann wäre ich zufrieden
eigentlich
naja oder auch meinen urlaub fährt und
doch das flugzeug nimmt das ist ja auch
dass es vielleicht ein großes flasche
oder so wo ich aber schon persönlich
glaube achte viel zu fahren wenn es
irgendwie geht aber übers meer fahren
will
es ist natürlich sehr aufwendig so würde
ich sagen ja also ich glaube bei mir ist
es was mir spontan als erstes einfällt
viel mit umwelt verbunden
[Musik]
der zweite zufall des tages auch nicht
abgesprochen
steffi hier sind viele bekannte
gesichter auf diesem in diesem mauerpark
steffi wir reden heute über guilty
pleasures so kleine laster dinge die man
später bereut
hast du da etwas kleine laster das haben
wir so andere beispiele gebracht
die klassiker sind als und süßigkeiten
zu viel geld ausgeben kiffen knüpfen das
macht ja die ganze zeit finger kriegen
und so wie geht das kannst du noch mal
zeigen fingerschnipsen nervosität denn
sobald ich nervös wird halt um gespielt
was anderes machen was ich machen wollte
hast du ein beispiel
heute wollte ich zum beispiel rausgehen
und stattdessen unseren abschluss von
der spüle bereinigt also klassische
prokrastination bei uns im freundeskreis
guilty pleasure auch immer so ein
bisschen werden effekte was die leute
von mir denken würden
und was ein teaser zu dem bild passt was
du zu anderen anderen hatten wir mittel
und das wäre auf jeden fall dass ich ein
pokémon fan bin
du wirst pokémon fans gerne alle spiele
gespielt und kaufe mir die auch immer
noch innen heraus kommen und es ist aber
jetzt gerade keine schlechte
angewohnheit weil ich liebe ja pokemon
deswegen will das geht so nicht
aber tatsächlich liebe ich es einfach so
gerne süßigkeiten zu essen
das hat mir schwer davon abstand zu
nehmen was denn am nächsten für
süßigkeiten kinder bueno
davon merken denn in eurem du darfst
alles ist ja unser projekt wir können
machen wir wollen ja als süßigkeiten
tatsächlich wollte ich mal aufhören zu
essen und jetzt habe ich wieder
angefangen tatsächlich ja also zeiten
sind schon ja würde ich mich anschließen
werden also da muss ich jetzt sagen das
ist nicht mein ding das ist doch doof
wenn man sich dann nachher darüber ja
gehabt
das sind doch also ich hab doch ganz
viele sachen die ich gerne mache und
dann freue ich mich darüber
ja das muss ich jetzt noch keiner ein
sagt mal ein beispiel keine ahnung die
der halbe kilo es den mann dann ist weil
man gerade bock drauf hat das ist jetzt
nichts wo ich mich dafür schämen freue
ich mich dass ein halbes kilo eis
gegessen habe okay das eine ist ein
zucker laster mit der schokolade das
andere ist das rauchen was natürlich
auch ein laster ist
[Musik]
genießt du das rauchen dann trotzdem
noch oder ist es nur noch schuldgefühl
mittlerweile ist das kein schuldgefühl
werden also es ist ich glaube wenn ich
lust habe eine zigarette zu rauchen
ja aber nicht ultra regelmäßig bei einem
schönen glas wein zum beispiel was ist
denn deine lieblings eissorte weiße
weiße schokolade vanille
hauptsächlich war noch mal zu pannen ich
liebe käse ich esse einfach zu viel käse
manchmal an und sage ich mir das hätte
ich wirklich nicht machen sollen
was ist denn dein lieblings käse ist
jetzt nicht so exciting aber mein
persönliches guilty pleasure ist lakritz
kennt ihr das das ist so eine schwarze
süßigkeit gibt es in salzig und in süß
ist sehr beliebt in deutschland und in
skandinavien glaube ich in vielen
anderen ländern kennt man das glaube ich
gar nicht so aber müsst ihr mal
probieren
ich esse da zuviel von und jetzt
interessiert mich natürlich was ist euer
guilty pleasure euer kleines alltags
laster schreibt uns einen kommentar in
den kommentaren
und wenn ihr lust habt werdet doch ein
mitglied von the german dann bekommt ihr
übungen zu diesem video und einiges an
zusatzmaterial vielen dank bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]